foreign
I just wanted to go through
um you know the human microbiome or how
it affects the uh our health and well
awareness and also talk a little bit
about the different Vantage points
through which you can view the human
microbiome and how those different
Vantage points actually affect the way
uh we can treat the treat the microbiome
itself
um just running through the basics so
that um if if anybody doesn't know what
the microbiome is uh we can get a quick
glance of of what it is and how it
affects us
um so the microbiome is predominantly
you know talked about the guy is talked
about with respect to the gut microbiome
um but we also
um you know there's a lot of work and
results that's been done on the oral
microbiome the skin microbiome and and
several other parts of of the body the
entire Collective is is known as the
human microbiome or the microbiota
um so our body has over a hundred
trillion microbes and the shear number
itself is
um you know it's it's uh more than
probably 10 times the number of human
cells in our body
this
um number influences our health and and
wellness in in a big way 95 of these
microbes are actually located uh in in
our gut which is which is why the gut
microbiome has has played such a huge
and significant role
um in microbiome research as well as uh
in in the research of uh disease
um
you know the causation of disease and
and how to cure it as well
um so if you if you just took the
microbes from the gut and and you made
them that'll be
um that itself would be around 2 kg so
that's the
significance of of how large the
microbiome is
I think all this the uh microbiome of an
individual is is very unique it's it's
very it's it's almost like a fingerprint
not that it's permanent it's it's
transient it changes over time and and
as changes over time the uh the
fingerprint also changes